>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, DC.
>> Al Banks: So my
name is Al Banks,
and I'm the Chief Operating
Officer for Library Services
and so I'd like to welcome you
to the Library of Congress.
On behalf of the Librarian
of Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden
and our entire team, I'd like
to welcome you and thank you
for choosing to today's Gold
Star Legacy Panel Discussion.
The Veterans History Project is
one of the most popular projects
at the Library of
Congress, and is considered
on of the largest oral history
projects in the country.
Through a Congressional
Mandate to collect,
preserve and make accessible.
The memories of our nation's
veterans we hear directly
from them what they
saw, felt and heard.
The human experience
of military service.
These first hand narratives
reinforced the realities
of their selfless service
so that we all better
understand and appreciate them.
When the Gold Star
Families Voices Act
of 2016 amended the Veterans
History Project legislation its
scope expanded to
include oral histories
from immediate family
members of the armed forces
who became missing in action
or who died as a result
of their wartime service.
This revision reinforces our
dedication to making sure
that all military
veterans are not forgotten,
but instead are heard,
appreciated and remembered
with a lasting, living legacy.
Through our work with the
Gold Start individuals
and organizations, some
of whom are here today,
we are able to demonstrate
to these families
and the American people that
the legacy of these heroes is
in the memory of
a grateful nation.
This Sunday marks Gold Star
Mothers and Families Day
which is observed in the
US on the last Sunday
of September each year.
We are pleased to
commemorate this day
with this landmark
panel discussion.
In a few moments you will
hear from the leaders
of Gold Star organizations
and individuals
who will explore ways that
families, organizations
and communities are
currently working to honor
and preserve the legacy
of our fallen members
of our service members.
They will also highlight ways
in which we all can support
families of the fallen,
and ensure their loved ones
are honored and remember,
and remembered in
a suitable way.
At this time, I'm delighted
to introduce today's Gold
Star Legacy panel moderator.
Emmy Award Winning News
Correspondent Mr. Mort Dean.
As a correspondent of CBS News
20 years ago, and with ABC
for 14 years, his many
assignments includes the US
space program, political
campaigns and the Vietnam War.
Putting himself in harm's
way, Mr. Dean reported
on the invasion of Grenada,
the [inaudible] War,
and Cuba from the early days
of the Castro regime
through the present.
He reported on Iran
when the hostage crisis
from Somalia during
the US intervention,
the turmoil in Israel and
the Palestinian territory
and the military action in
Kosovo involving US marines.
He covered Saddam Hussain's
Iraq, the NATO air attacks
in Belgrade, the terror attack
on the USS Cole in Yemen,
the bombing of the US embassy in
Nairobi, and the US retaliation
in Sudan as well as the first
terrorist terrorists attacks
on the World Trade
Center in 1993.
With his more recent endeavors,
Mr. Dean has written, directed
and produced a PBS
documentary, American Medivac.
The documentary tells the story
of a harrowing medivac mission
to rescue three wounded soldiers
from enemy fire in a rice patty.
Mr. Dean long wondered what
had become of the medivac troop
and the bloody men
who were airlifted
to safety on that day in 1971.
American Medivac is a story
of their reunion more
than 40 years later.
It is my pleasure to welcome
and introduce Mr. Mort Dean.
[ Applause ]
>> Mort Dean: That was so long,
that introduction that you,
you probably think I wrote
it, but I had nothing to do,
to do with is, and I have to
say given the current attitude
in among some people,
including the Commander in Chief
about reporters, I think
it's very gutsy of you all
to have me here today.
And, and if any of you
are still on active duty,
I wonder what this is going to
mean to you and your future.
I'm very honored to be here
and to be in your company
and thank you Library
of Congress for caring
about America, for caring
about Gold Star families,
and thank you New Day USA for
caring about America and caring
about Gold Star families.
Anyone who knows a Gold
Star family is well aware
that Gold Star mothers
and fathers and brothers
and sisters, Gold Star
families often wear a gold star,
but they also carry a
gold star in their hearts.
And I believe it's the duty
of all Americans to reach
into those hearts, to
touch those gold stars,
to embrace them with
our love and respect.
And to polish them
up a little bit
and make them a little
less burdensome to carry.
And show that we too,
the civilians care.
That we too will
never, ever forget.
That's why I'm here and that's
why New Day USA is here,
and has brought many
of us together today.
It's why others of you are
here also to say to those
who carry a gold
star in their hearts
that you are not alone today,
and you will never be alone,
and America truly
cares about you.
We're going to hear more
about that from our panel
in just a moment
about what the they
and their organizations are
doing for Gold Star families
and what we and our
government needs to do.
I was at an event, a meeting
in Washington just a couple
of weeks ago, and the
discussion did get
around to Gold Star families.
It was a meeting of the Vietnam
War Commemoration Commission,
Steering Committee.
And we were talking about
Gold Stars and families
and the activities
that are taking place
in Washington this
coming weekend.
And an old soldier, a
former, a current medal
of honor recipient
said that he was
in a gold star family
event just a couple
of years ago here in Washington.
And he raised the question,
he said how many members
of Congress are out there?
Nobody. How many members
of a Congressional
office are out there?
Nobody. And he turned to the
crowd the other day and said,
this is one of the jobs we
have to do to convince people
in the highest offices of our
country that there are people
out there who deserve
the government's care
and respect and honor.
So let me introduce the people
on the panel, Jenine Melton,
US Army Veteran, two tours in
Iraq and a Gold Star sister.
What does the term
Gold Star mean to you?
>> Jenine Melton: When I
think of the term Gold Star,
to me it symbolizes sacrifice,
the ultimate sacrifice
that our fallen heroes made
to preserve our freedom.
So every time I look at the
gold star, it reminds me
that freedom is not free.
There is a fallen hero that
made the ultimate sacrifice,
and then there is a
family that's associated
with every single star.
So when you see the service
flag hanging in a window,
or a magnet on the back
of somebody's car there's
a story behind every star,
a story of pain, a story of
sacrifice and a story ultimately
of love and we should
never forget that.
>> Mort Dean: Yeah my
understanding is what I said is
that when you mentioned
Gold Star to,
to many people they don't know
what you're talking about,
it's not the way it was
when I was a kid growing up,
just after World War
II when you would go
through the neighborhood
and see gold stars hanging
in the windows of
so many families.
Have you found that true?
>> Jenine Melton: Yes
I was actually amazed.
Coming from active duty, prior
to the passing of my brother,
I did not know and there
were actually some chaplains
that I had met when
I was on active duty
and separated that did not know.
So right now, and I find it
to be my personal mission
to make people aware of that.
To let them know about the
sacrifice associated with that.
Even currently I'm a
civil servant working
with the Department
of Veteran Affairs
and they've been really trying
to do more with initiatives
with veterans and even talking
about Gold Star families,
but really a lot of
people do not know,
which is why I'm glad we
have platforms like this
to promote awareness
and make people aware
of our family sacrifices
and our heroes.
>> Mort Dean: Becky
Christmas is President
of the American Gold
Star Mothers, Inc.
And I read something about
when you were named president,
and you said in your,
your thank you speech,
we are mothers on a mission.
What is your mission?
>> Becky Christmas: The mission
of American Gold Star Mothers,
Incorporated, is to serve
and support veterans
and the families of the fallen
and our active military.
We are a veteran service
organization, 90 years old.
It was started in 1928
by a Gold Star mother
who lost her son in World War I.
And that is our mission.
And so our theme this year
is Mothers On A Mission,
A Powerful Force,
because we do have a voice
that people will listen to.
And it's important, because
we can speak for some
of our veterans that aren't able
to, and some of our families
that aren't able to, and
that is, that is what we do
to take our grief, serve in a
positive way, because grief held
within can be destructive.
So we learned that and we feel
that service is our mission.
>> Mort Dean: And Becky
you really know what you're
talking about.
Your son served in Iraq.
>> Becky Christmas: Yes.
>> Mort Dean: Tell us about him.
>> Becky Christmas: My son
was Captain Todd Christmas.
Todd was very proud
to serve in the army.
That was all he ever
wanted to do.
And he hoped to have
a long career.
He was deployed to Iraq in 2003,
and he was the recipient
of a bronze star.
He was a ranch boy
from New Mexico
who could be quite
innovative with things
that maybe they didn't have
or things they needed to do,
and he was determined to
do those kinds of things
that needed to be done,
to help with his mission.
So he returned in late, in early
2004, from Iraq, and was chosen
to be an Aid to General Ben
Allen at Fort Hood, Texas.
And unfortunately the
money after Thanksgiving,
there were seven
on a helicopter,
including General Allen and
Colonel Jim Moore and they were,
they hit a communication
tower outside of Fort Hood
in heavy fog, and all perished.
But we were blessed to have a
close relationship with our son.
And he loved his job.
He told me every day when
he got up to go to work,
he loved what he was doing.
>> Mort Dean: Thank you Becky.
General William Caldwell,
to mention where General
Caldwell has been during a long
and illustrious career in the US
military would take probably the
rest of this afternoon
and we'd have
to serve drinks this
evening and just continue,
not a bad idea by the way.
Currently he is the President of
Georgia Military Prep College.
He has helped facilitate
the awarding
of New Day USA scholarships to
children of Gold Star families
and children of disabled
veterans.
General how important is it for
a family to learn as so many
of your students have learned
from having received
scholarships from New Day USA,
how it, important is it for them
to know that there are people
out there that they don't
even know who really care
about who they are and
what they've been through?
>> Lt. Gen. William B.
Caldwell: Well Mort thanks.
I, I'm glad we didn't go
through my, my history.
I wasn't sure if you were
just saying that I'm older
than you or not though.
I do want to say it really is
important for us to remember.
Everybody up here will tell you
that we don't want
to ever forget.
I feel very blessed today that
I've been able to be a part
of a life of the young
lady there, Carolyn Wood,
who lost her father,
and she's at our school.
She's attending there.
We've got some other kids
who are also Gold Star family
children that are at our school,
and we're incredibly blessed in
our ability to remember them,
that we hold a ceremony
every 9-11 and during
that ceremony we lay a wreath.
And it's done in remembrance of
those who lost their fathers,
mothers, brothers, sisters.
In our case its two fathers
and four young children
that are there that we go out
and do this lay the wreath.
We're in military uniforms
at this preparatory school,
the fourth through 12th grade.
But what makes it really
special today for us is the fact
that New Day stepped forward.
Rob Posner stepped
forward and said I,
I want to help these
families and I know
that you charge a
tuition to go there.
It's like a charter school.
And I want to relieve
their parents, their mother
or their father,
whomever is raising them
of all financial burden
to attend that school.
And we've been just
enormously blessed,
and that he's now
been doing that.
His company has, New Day has.
And it makes an enormous
difference on those families
when there are other
Americans who recognize
that the sacrifice is enduring,
it's not a one-time sacrifice,
it's a, it's a life
commitment that somebody made
to our nation for others.
And the fact that
New Day has done
that is making a
remarkable difference
in our little community there
in Milledgeville, Georgia.
At that ceremony I'll share.
We just started a fourth
and fifth grade this year.
We added on to this
preparatory school we have.
And it's all day
students, about 700.
And I was chatting with some of
the fourth graders last week.
And I asked them, I said what's
the one thing you've really
enjoyed so far being a part
of this preparatory school.
This little fourth grade
gal raises her hand.
She goes, I learned what
it means to do something
for somebody else
and give your life.
I've never been taught
that before.
And I said well what
do you mean?
She goes, well that 9-11
thing that you all did.
She said, when we came out there
and listened to the stories,
and heard of people doing
something for somebody else
by giving their life,
we realized that there are some
great Americans around here.
And this is coming out of
the mouth of a fourth grader.
And so I just, I, I think
we all, as a nation,
need to constantly remind
ourselves just how blessed we
are by having men
and women, you know,
who will serve their
nation like they have
and to therefore
remember their families
continuously thereafter.
But anyway, so--
>> Mort Dean: Thank you General.
And while I, I visited the
college and met the General,
last year I guess it was.
And not all that long ago.
And he was dressed in
his full dress uniform.
And he was walking through
the corridor and I thought,
oh this is going
to be interesting,
all of the students are going
to shrink back and they're going
to be frightened
by his presence.
But it was just the opposite.
And it just struck me that
given the proper introduction
to people in uniform, being
told what the uniform means,
really does change their--
the attitude of young people
so that they respect people
in uniform, and they think
of them not as some obscure
people, but as friends,
people who care about them
and they in turn end up caring
about people like yourself.
Bonnie Carroll, a veteran,
Founder and President of TAPS,
Tragedy Assistance
Programs for Survivors.
Recipient of the
Presidential Medal of Freedom,
which is not-- it's a big deal.
A Gold Star spouse.
Tell us a little bit about TAPS.
>> Bonnie Carroll: Well in
1992 my husband was killed
in an army plane crash along
with seven other soldiers.
And like Becky, and her son,
my husband was a combat veteran
and a recipient of the Bronze
Star and the Air Medal.
We certainly did not expect
that his career would
end in that way.
So I immediately went looking
for the kind of the support
that I knew had to
exist for other types
of loss of our society.
Immediately became a life
member of Gold Star Wives.
And worked with the
Department of Veterans Affairs,
the Department of Defense to
identify any gaps that existed.
The support that I found in
Gold Star Wives and talking
with other organizations
was fantastic,
but what was most valuable
was the peer connection,
being with others
who truly understood
in a very personal way
because they were also walking
this journey.
Back in the early '90s there was
no organization in partnership
with Gold Star Wives,
Gold Star Mothers,
Society of Military Widows
to address some of the nuts
and bolts, the casework
assistance,
the peer based emotional
support and grief counseling.
A 24/7 help line that
could be maintained
by trained peer mentors.
Connections to free
and unlimited clinical
grief counseling,
if additional support
was required.
So in 1994, TAPS was launched
and immediately was embraced
by the Defense Department
as a wonderful compliment
to the other organizations and
to what the government could do.
Today General Dempsey, former
Chairman of the Joint Chiefs,
is on our Board of Directors.
And he puts it beautifully.
He says, the government
does a magnificent job
of administering benefit's,
and rendering final
honors when a death occurs.
We honor all those who
have given their lives
for this country.
But what we can't do in
the military is be there
for the emotional support,
for the additional financial
assistance, for the connections
to the educational
benefits that are offered
in the private sector, for the
24/7 resource that is given
by peers who truly understand.
So we've had the support
since the very early days
of every chairman who has
directed the families,
or referred and connected to
the support that TAPS can offer.
And it is a family,
it's a family of all
of us Gold Star Wives, Gold
Star mothers, siblings, dads,
together on this
journey honoring those
who have served and died.
>> Mort Dean: Thank you.
And I hope we'll all
participate later
on in discussing what more we
can all do to show that we care
and how we, what we can
do to energize others,
especially people in
the halls of Congress,
and in official Washington
to realize
that they do have a
lot more to accomplish.
Dale Egan is Vice President
of the Hershel Woody
Williams Foundation.
And their memorials are all
around the country
honoring those
who have given their
lives to our country.
You've, you've erected
many, many memorials
around the country, what purpose
do you think they really serve?
>> Chad Graham: That's
a good question.
I subbed out Dale today.
Dale wasn't able
to make it, so I--
>> Mort Dean: Oh--
>> Chad Graham: I'm
Chad, Chad Graham,
President of Hershel Woody
Williams Foundation--
>> Mort Dean: No, nobody--
>> Chad Graham: You
expected Dale,
but you didn't get him, so--
>> Mort Dean: And I'm
not really Mort Dean,
I am just-- I'm just--
>> Chad Graham: No that's fine,
I just didn't want them to think
that Dale was this
ugly, so you know.
No but I am, I am, I am honored
to be here and, and that's,
that's a great question.
And I think the best answer that
I can offer is what I've heard
from these Gold Star families
that are sitting up here,
and the Gold Star
families that are out here.
And, and that sacrifice, and
what that monument means.
In terms of, of going into these
communities, so many communities
as you started out with, they,
they don't know what
a Gold Star family is.
And we have a duty, as
you said, to, to everyone
and the general public.
We need to lead this movement
to put that on the forefront.
And within our communities,
every community needs to realize
that there are Gold Star
families living amongst them.
And that the reason they
can have the community,
and the reason that we can live
the lives that we've had is
because somebody else laid
down their life for it and paid
that ultimate sacrifice.
And what our hope is that
these monuments act as a way,
a gathering place for that,
something that can serve
as a launch pad for Gold Star
mothers, Gold Star wives,
Gold Star siblings, Gold Star
children for all those folks
to gather, because it is
for them, and it is theirs
to use as they see fit.
And from the public side
they, they get an education
about what, what is a Gold Star
family, and what does that mean
and hopefully that, that grows.
And we can be a small part of
that and be a catalyst for that.
And our hope is that each
one of these monuments now
that we have 40 by the end of
the year we'll have about 50
that have been established
across the United States,
that those serve as,
as a starting point.
Those monuments are
there as a way that,
that we can gather
these Gold Star families
and also keep it fresh
on the communities mind,
because as we've all heard,
it is so, so important for us
to say every day, those loved
ones names who have fallen.
And the only way we can keep
that in the public eye is
to have something
that is permanent,
and something there
that's in the public view.
>> Mort Dean: That's good.
So whatever your name really is,
but why did you get
involved in, in this project?
>> Chad Graham: Our family
kind of came together in 2010.
We were getting to, to
celebrate our fifth birthday
as an organization.
But about 2010, and we're really
talking about the, the influence
of my grandfather,
Woody Williams, who,
whose the namesake
of, of the foundation.
At a young age, when he tried
to enter the Marine
Corps he was turned
down because they had
a height requirement
that he did not fit at the time.
His, in the interim between them
lowering the height requirement.
He was actually delivering
Western Union telegrams
to families, that was
a notice of death.
And my grandfather, that had
such a huge impact on him.
And I remember from the time
I was a little guy we used
to show horses together.
And we'd be riding
around the countryside
and he would tell
me these stories.
Because it was always
something that he taught us.
He taught us that leadership
is service, and that service
above self there is nothing
more righteous on this planet
that any of us can do.
And that was always a part
of the fabric of our family.
When we started talking about
formalizing a foundation,
none of us had any idea.
We definitely didn't,
didn't have the funding
to start a foundation.
We didn't really
have that direction.
I think divine intervention
had a hand in it,
and I think the biggest thing
is, is our, our duty is,
is to do what we're doing.
And so for me, as, as a family
member, outside of that a,
a few years back when we,
we really started
formalizing the organization,
I saw it personally as, as
something of a calling to me.
It's part of my personal mission
and, and it's very important
to all of us in the
organization.
I think we're very,
very fortunate
that everybody involved shares
in that personal
commitment to our mission.
>> Mort Dean: Good, good.
Thank you.
And I know some of you have some
questions and some comments,
and I hope you all participate,
just raise your hand
and we'll be able to hear you.
If not, a microphone
will be at your side.
Rob you start.
>> Rob: [Inaudible]
it's an honor for us
to be here today at New Day.
It's an honor for us to
be here in New Day USA,
and be supportive of, of
the Gold Star families.
And I guess a question
that I would have is,
what could companies like
New Day and the community
to do more, to help
more Gold Star families?
Because I think that [inaudible]
General Caldwell this,
this school that he has, at
Georgia Military College,
it's really an amazing, an
amazing place to raise children.
And I think that any child
that's a son or daughter
of a Gold Star family, it
would just be incredible
if we could be helping
more Gold Star families.
In terms of, if we're on the
phone, the Admiral Tyler Lynch,
our Chairman and
myself are on the phone
with many Gold Star families.
And you know, we, we have some
understanding of, of the pain
and sacrifice just from our
conversations that we have
with Gold Star families.
And one of the things
that we see is
that if we can help the children
of these Gold Star families be
in the right environment for
high school, it's not a question
of college, because a lot
of these Gold Star children
never get to college.
And if we can get them
a boost and a step up,
in terms of getting them
the right education,
then more, very positive.
So what can we do to find
more Gold Star families,
help more Gold Star children,
and what can the community do,
not just obviously New
Day, to, to help educate?
I think the education is the
greatest gift we can give
in terms of healing for
these Gold Star families,
but thank you Mort.
>> Mort Dean: Yeah thank you.
Go ahead.
>> Bonnie Carroll:
Thank you so much Rob,
thank you for everything
that New Day does.
And thank you for being here,
and you're absolutely right.
The children of America's fallen
heroes have been given federal
benefits through the
Department of Veterans Affairs
to expand the GI bill,
the Frye Scholarship.
There are also state
waivers of fees and tuition
and private scholarships
and programs like yours.
It's absolutely essential
that we let the families
know in an organized way.
I work very closely with
all of our partner VSOs
and military service
organizations.
And through TAPS we
have an education portal
that families can go in, log
in, and get a list of everything
that they're available,
that they're eligible for.
And then we help them
work through that
so that they can figure
out what's the right way
to structure their
benefit's to meet their goals,
their educational goals.
I appreciate we, we've
worked with you all
and it's good to
see you again sir.
And it is absolutely essential
that we get the benefit's
and the resources
that are available
to the families to them.
That's one of the goals
that the TAPS has.
So it's at TAPS.org,
the education portal.
And we've got to reach
every Gold Star family
and let them know that
there is support available
and there are resources
for education services,
absolutely essential.
So thank you.
>> Becky Christmas: I'd
like to add to that also.
I think that can also reach out
to all the other organizations
in addition to TAPS, but
Gold Star Wives of America,
American Gold Star Mothers,
because we do have services
that we provide for veterans and
we, we don't always have the,
the manpower or the way to
get all that information out.
So we're volunteering in the
VA hospitals, and we see needs
for the veterans
in the hospitals.
Clothing, maybe newspaper
subscriptions,
maybe laptops, things like that.
We volunteer in the
clinics, in small communities
like where I come from.
We, we go, we sit in the,
in the waiting room visiting
with veterans, and they'll
tell you their story,
and they will tell you what they
need or what their barriers are
that they're trying to
overcome, to get benefit's or,
or just everyday living
things that they need.
And so we, we try to help them
with the sources they need,
or the direction
to go get those.
But sometimes they don't
have a strong enough voice
as I was saying, to, so
we sometimes have to go
with them personally
to do those things.
We also volunteer in VA centers
where of course a veteran is
going to come to find out,
you know, what benefit's
he might get,
or help get his paperwork
in order,
and we try to steer
them that way.
But then we work with stand
down, homeless veterans.
When you go to a stand down,
and you see the veterans
on the street and the fact
that they need a haircut,
they need a dental exam
and all of those things,
there are resources there
that, that we, we really need
to help those, those veterans.
The families of the fallen,
sometimes when the
initial casualty officer is
with the families of, of
a family of the fallen,
and then they're gone, and maybe
they don't remain in contact,
a few-- for me I
know it was two years
down the road before I really
was ready to even talk about a,
an organization where I
could volunteer my services.
So we need to, we need to make
sure those families maintain
that information and
know who to contact.
And they don't always do that.
They, they've lost the
paperwork, you know,
for if they're a wife.
They, they, you know, they
may have children and they,
that's what they've had
to concentrate on and
yet they need something for
themselves, people to talk to.
So maybe they need
an organization
like Gold Star wives or a mother
needs someone else to talk
to that's besides her
husband, you know about,
because they're sharing
that grief.
So those, the information
about the organizations,
the actual physical work that
we need to do for our veterans,
those things are sources,
resources that we really need.
>> Mort Dean: Yes ma'am.
>> Mona Gun: I don't need a
mike I don't think I have a
loud voice.
>> Mort Dean: We
all need a mike.
>> Mona Gun: I am Mona
Gun, I'm a Gold Star mom.
And my son pre-9/11, one of
the sailors that was killed
on board the USS Cole, so I
appreciate what you've done
if you're reported
on that bombing.
That pre-9/11 families
are sometimes left
out of many, many things.
And my son was not married,
he was a single young many
who followed dad's footsteps.
Went into the Navy
and my husband had a 21 year
very successful Navy career
and my son, nine
months and he was gone.
And our family was
torn apart, you know.
I have three other sons.
My oldest son found a way
to deal with his grief.
Sharom who was killed had
two younger brothers, twins.
My boys were in college
during that time.
There's very little out
there for siblings, and for,
for parents and families,
when there is a single
service member that is killed.
Of course the VA, the Department
of Defense, are right there
for spouses and for the children
of fallen, but siblings there,
there was very little.
My boys, to this
day, were in college
and have not finished
their degree.
Mom's got two degrees,
daddy got two degrees.
So any kind of support that
you can give for siblings,
I don't know if you're aware
of any sibling programs
that will provide
college support will be
greatly appreciated.
I have found-- I
found Gold Star Moms
that helped me tremendously,
my oldest son did some things
to keep alive the
service of his brother.
But my boys, the twins, to this
day are still dealing with,
and it will be 18 years for us.
They were in college, so if you
know of any programs out there,
if you all know of any
programs or any things out there
that could support
siblings is critical.
>> Mort Dean: Thank you.
Is, is there a, a list or
somewhere where people can go
who have questions like that?
>> Jenine Melton: Well we have
a sibling and it's very true,
because there were not a
lot of things out there.
And since I've recently gotten
more involved into TAPS,
I joined what's called
a Peer Mentor Program.
And that's a program
where we do some training,
and then they assign
you with a peer mentor
who has experienced
a similar loss.
And it's essentially
a network of siblings
that support each other.
We also have routine calls where
we have webcasts where we talk
and communicate with each
other, and support, and just try
to establish that outreach.
So I would say TAPS has
done an excellent job
in establishing that program.
And then also they have other
programs within the summertime
where they have certain things
for siblings, for camps,
and other activities and
outreach things that you can do.
And I know also with
the Maryland Chapter
of Gold Star Mothers, I've
gotten involved with some
of the other siblings
there trying to partner
and do other outreach
things that we can do
in honor of our fallen heroes.
So that's one thing that I'm
really trying to make sure
that I try to lean forward
on and trying to get involved
with the TAPS program,
doing things
with the American
Gold Star Mothers.
And then even things
within our community to try
to bring more siblings in
because sometimes we do feel
like we have been forgotten.
But I'm glad to see
that programs like TAP
and the American Gold
Star Mothers is starting
to wrap their arms
around the siblings
and saying we haven't
forgotten you, we love you
and we're here for you.
So that's what I'm
personally trying to do.
I'm making sure that I
make other siblings aware
of these programs to
support each other.
>> Mort Dean: That's great.
Any? Yes sir.
>> Audience: Yeah I
was in Long Beach,
California for the annual
meeting of the Mothers,
and one [inaudible] came out of
that there were 22 suicides
per day of veterans.
I just want to make [inaudible]
a lot more [inaudible].
>> Becky Christmas: Thank you.
For the last two years
we have had a major focus
on military suicide
awareness because this is one
of those unspoken sort of
hidden in the back issues
that I think we as Americans
have overlooked for a long time.
And so we started that
program last year,
and we have done quite
a lot to raise money
for Working Dogs for
Vets, especially.
And so we've continued
that mission this year.
And that mission is, is
going to go on because this,
this is a serious,
serious issue.
Sometimes it's years after
one of our service men
or women have left the service
and years later they
die by suicide.
So there are many programs,
many things that are out there
but we need to make people aware
of those, they need support.
And as I said, we have worked
with Working Dogs for Vets,
which is based in Tennessee
for the last two years.
They've been quite successful
with service dogs for those
who have those tendencies,
suffer from TBI or PSD.
And so we are really focused on
this, and we are very serious
about this, and we are trying
to make every American aware
to help with this issue.
>> Mort Dean: Tell me if, if
you've had this experience.
I, I think you probably
have had.
But in, in prepping
for this documentary
and a few other things that
I've, I've been working on,
I have found that often
when you go to a veteran,
or you make a cold call,
somebody you know who has been
in the service, and you say
look I'm working on something,
I want to talk to you
about your service.
It's usually, well
thank you very much,
but I'm not interested, I, I
wish you good luck with it.
And I have found that,
that just saying thank you
for your service which to some
people is [inaudible] now,
is not enough.
That as a good friend of mine
who did duty in Vietnam has said
to crowds, said,
what we really want
to know is that you love us.
That you really care about us.
Anybody can say thank
you, but you know,
ask me what's really going on.
And it's been amazing to me
how many people have responded
to that, and have said, well
call me back we'll talk.
And you know we've made a
number of friends simply
by proving that we care.
Does that make sense
to you General?
>> Lt. Gen. William B. Caldwell:
I, I think it really does.
I remember the first time we
did the welcome home ceremony
for our Vietnam veterans back
in 2000, it was right around 13
at Fort Sam Houston, Texas.
And it was one of the first in
the nation that the veterans,
you know, group had
started talking about doing
through the Department
of Defense.
And we signed up and
said we'd love to do it.
And I can tell you it
wasn't the ceremony itself,
it was the aftermath, it
was the reception area,
inside the quadrangle that you
saw the emotions just running
tremendously high with
everybody hugging each other.
And young people, young soldiers
that were there going up
and hugging these
veterans and telling them,
thank you for what
you did during a time
when our nation really
was not very grateful
for your willingness to
sacrifice for others.
And gosh it was, it
was a moving ceremony.
I remember Joe [inaudible] came
out for it and he was there,
he was heading up that group
and it, it does if you,
if you spend the time to
really tell them how much,
it's not just the thank you for
what you did, but truly we, we,
we can feel it deep inside the
realization that you were ready
to make that sacrifice that
had been required, and,
and you're home now and
we just need to know
that we really do appreciate
it, appreciate them.
>> Mort Dean: There
are some of you
who have not raised your hand
so I'm going to just call.
There you go, I knew
it would work.
Go ahead.
>> Audience: Thank you.
I lost my son-in-law,
2005, Lieutenant,
First Lieutenant Charlie Owens
who was an electronic
warfare officer
and Special Operations
Squadron Seven
out of Mendenhall, England.
And he was killed in a low
level night training mishap
in Albania.
His oldest son was five, his
youngest son was six weeks old.
So but what I wanted to
say, on behalf of my family,
thank you for all that you do.
We have had so much
support from TAPS,
from Special Operations
Warrior Foundation,
from Gold Star Teen
Adventures, all of these things.
And it has meant so much
to us and so much to them
and so I just want
to say thank you.
>> Mort Dean: And, and
that sense that you need,
that you need people it
never really ends doesn't it?
Don't you find that
you're still reaching
out to these organizations?
Yeah. Yes sir.
>> Lt. Colonel Retired
Mike Salmons:
Lieutenant Colonel
Retired Mike Salmons
on staff here are the Library.
Also a retired medivac pilot.
I want to echo Bob's comments
about all that you have done.
I have recently got involved
in the Travis Manion
Foundation out of Pennsylvania.
Travis was a marine who lost
his life in Afghanistan.
And some of the Gold Star
families that are associated
with them have reeled
me in, if you will.
And I can't get enough
of that foundation.
So coincidence this Sunday
morning at dawn we will gather
with about 500 runners
and about 100 volunteers
and I will help put
on a road race
up in Baltimore for
that foundation.
And it's-- we need to see it as
another resource of your work
in the community,
because not only do,
does this foundation bring
together Gold Star families,
but it also takes young
veterans and puts them back
out into the community to
teach courses on leadership
and integrity and courage and
it, it's, it's their action
out in the communities that
helps bring those goals
to our parents together,
and veterans.
So I am totally blown away with
their work, and I'm honored
to be a part of that effort.
And a part of that
is probably resourced
to you also, thank you also.
>> Mort Dean: Thank you.
Thank you.
Anybody else over-- ?
>> Becky Christmas: I
was just going to say--
>> Mort Dean: Go ahead.
>> Becky Christmas:
Before we get off that.
We have quite a few Gold
Star families that work
within the Travis
Manion Foundation.
In fact we have a family
from New Mexico where I'm
from that work, he's
a contractor.
He's a builder and he
works with them quite a lot
and I think they are
going to New York
for something to build houses.
So that, that's a
great organization too.
And that's another
way to show patriotism
to young people for our country.
And get them involved
hands on to
to do some positive
things to help others.
So I'm glad you brought
that one up.
>> Mort Dean: I'd
like to, go ahead.
>> Janice Chance: If I could.
>> Janice Chance: Hi,
I am Janice Chance,
and I'm the proud mother of
Captain Jessie Melton, III,
United States Marine Corps.
He served 11 years and he was
killed while supporting combat
operations in Afghanistan
on 9/9/2008.
So this, a ten years,
was ten years for him,
and we celebrated his life.
But I've been a mess, and of
course this is my daughter,
Jenine Melton, Captain Jenine
Melton who, I had two serving
at the same time, so that
was truly a challenge.
But I have seen that after
the passing of my son,
the death of my son,
who made that sacrifice.
It was interesting on the
day that he was killed,
he was not scheduled
to be on duty,
but another marine asked
him to take his place.
And he was killed along with
First Lieutenant McDroso,
Mick McDroso [inaudible]
Strickland an
Afghan interpreter.
And two days later that
marine's baby was born on 9/11,
so a lot of good
things happen on 9/11,
plus it's my wedding
anniversary,
not that year, but that day.
But one of the things
you were saying as far
as saying just thank you,
go beyond the thank
you's is serving
in the Gold Star Mother we honor
to service and I'm a member
of TAPS and the Travis Manion
Foundation, I do a lot of work.
As a matter of fact
Sunday I'll be speaking
at the opening ceremony
for that.
But it is, when you go
to that and I volunteer
at the VA Medical
Healthcare System, Walter Reed
and the Office of the
American Red Cross.
And so listening to
those veteran stories
and just go beyond a thank you
and doing something
constructive.
So I encourage people
to volunteer,
put action behind that,
go up to them and say,
what do you need,
and begin to serve.
Listening to them.
You know I had a
Vietnam veteran.
One day I cam into the
office and he said,
you know I've never shared
my story about Vietnam.
And he said, but I feel today
that I can share that with you.
And so he did and
it was so special
and the Maryland Chapter we
decided to have a challenge
for me specifically for
Vietnam veterans because both
of my brothers served
in Vietnam, my cousins.
And so we had a commemorative
challenge coin made.
And so we give that
to Vietnam veterans.
And I was in the airport on my
way to the convention and I met,
I had on my t-shirt
with Jessie's picture.
And this gentleman came up
to me and said thank you.
And he said that he was a
Vietnam veteran and I said,
wait I have something for you.
And I reached in my purse and
I have the challenge coin.
And I said, thank you so
very much for your service
and sacrifice to our country
because you guys did not
receive the heroes welcome
that you so richly deserve.
And so I honor and
I solute you sir
for your sacrifice
and your service.
And he had tears in his
eyes and began to cry.
And I said thank
you so very much.
And that has been repeatedly.
I've done that so many times.
And just being there for them,
talking to the POW's and the,
at the, at the VA hospital
and I'm the Chaplain as well
so I've gotten to know
a lot of the veterans.
And so I was there one day and
one of the gentleman that was
at Poly High School,
he recognized my voice
and said Janice,
please come over here.
And he said, can
you pray with me?
And I had the honor
of praying with him,
and then I heard
another voice that said,
Janice, I know you too.
Can you pray with me afterwards?
And so it's three
people in a row.
So just doing things and it
has been an amazing journey
to be able to help out veterans.
And wanted to, thank
you New Day USA.
When I first walked into there
last year into their building,
and I said, you know I looked
around, I said you know what,
this is a new day at USA.
You know this is
a new day for USA
because they really present
new days for those veterans
who have served by helping them
to get mortgages for homes.
So thank you for giving new
days to a lot of families.
And I'm hoping that
can be extended
to Gold Star families as well.
Moms who will need.
That's something that some
of the organizations will do.
Reach back.
We thank you for the
veterans, and the families
as my daughter says,
attached to each fallen hero.
If you can do something to
help Gold Star mothers and all
who are struggling, maybe
you know single parents
who would need mortgages
and things
like that, helping them do that.
But you know just reaching out
and just sharing and serving
within the community,
really means a lot.
You know it's, you can allow, I
always allow God to take my pain
and turn it to pearls
of glory to help others.
It's therapeutic and as you
water so shall you be watered.
You can't hold things
in, you got to let it go,
have an open hand and
begin to let it come
through you, just like water.
Serving others.
You'll feel better and when
I leave VA hospital I can sit
in my car and say,
mission complete.
My son said he wanted
to go change the world
and make a difference
and do something
that would bring God glory,
something that people
would not forget.
Everywhere he went he did that
and now he passed the baton
to me and I'm running with it
and so is my, is my daughter,
and my husband and all
the rest of the family.
So I thank all of you for
being here today to support us
and so we can get the
story out about Gold Star.
>> Mort Dean: Thank you very--
>> Janice Chance: Thank
you and God bless you.
>> Mort Dean: Thank
you very much.
I'd like to call up Cadet
Caroline Wood, come on up here
for just a sec, whose from the
Prep School that New Day USA is,
where New Day USA was
helping to fund students.
You and I have done this before.
I met the Woods and Caroline's
mother at, at the school,
at the college about a
year and a half or so ago.
And her mother, like all of
the parents there said, oh no,
like she'll, the child is
scared, this is not going
to work, she hates cameras,
she hates microphones.
And she came up and was
the star that we had.
So it's, it's good, good
to see you, and your mom.
Just, just tell us what, what
it meant to you to realize
that virtually out of
the blue somebody called
to say we recognize the
loss in your family and we'd
like to become friends
and help you.
>> Cadet Caroline Wood:
It was, it was an honor
because it had been
like 12 years
after my father had passed.
And finally someone
remembered him and honored him.
>> Mort Dean: And that
relationship has stayed
with you, right when
you got that call,
you probably thought oh
well who are these people
and what do they want from us.
But it wasn't quite
that way was it?
>> Cadet Caroline Wood: No.
They wanted to give
a scholarship to pay
for my whole tuition at TMC.
>> Mort Dean: Well much
deserved, the whole family.
And I remember you telling me,
and I'm sorry to do this to you,
but you know reporters do things
like this, they, they see tears
and they, they say
more, more, more.
But I'm really not like that.
But you know we, we talked
about several things so when,
when I was at, at
your college, and,
and one of those things was
that, that you were impressed
with the continuation
of the relationship
of packages would
arrive and tell us,
tell us about, about that.
>> Cadet Caroline Wood: So New
Day gives you a team member.
And they'll email you, ask
you how your day's been going,
how your year's going.
They'll remember
everything about you.
And that's just the most,
it's just touching to know
that they are remembering you,
your father, everything
about you.
And they send you
packages in the mail, just,
just small little things.
>> Mort Dean: Lots of
candy I think you told me.
>> Cadet Caroline Wood: Yes.
Yes.
>> Mort Dean: Well and
Ms. Wood and a number
of the other children who
have, have lost their,
their parents or, their parents
have become terribly disabled a,
a number of these young
people said to me,
what Caroline has said, how
important the connection
with New Day has been, and
it, that it taught them
that in their lives,
when they grow up,
they know that they're
going to make a contribution
to something too, so this is
a legacy that you folks do
to keep, keep on giving.
Thank you.
I hope you don't hate me
for bringing you up here.
[ Applause ]
And now we have a gentleman,
Gary Morrison whose
going to come up.
He's a representative
of New Day USA.
And I'm told you're coming
up, don't you know that?
Gary Morrison ladies
and gentlemen.
[ Applause ]
It's all yours.
Carri would you like
us to present now?
>> Gary Morrison: I'll ask
Admiral Lynch to please stand
in front of the podium.
Karen if you would go
stand by Admiral Lynch.
One of the, the great
things they're doing here,
Carri could you stand
her by Admiral Lynch.
>> Carri: Me?
>> Gary Morrison: One
of the great things
they're doing here is the,
the Veterans History Project.
And I think everybody that's in
this room could probably help
with it, and it's a
terribly important effort.
They're basically creating
this oral and visual history
of service, and all kinds
of service, combat service,
service in war time, free time,
whenever, service is service.
And they asked us, as part
of this agreement that we,
and cooperation that we
currently have going,
to see if we could put
together some things.
And New Day is, is very humbled,
and we're always humbled
with every opportunity we
have to connect with people
in our community, especially
the families of those who serve.
Unfortunately their
stories often go untold.
That is why I'm grateful
to the Library of Congress
and the Veterans History
Project for allowing us to reach
out to these individuals
and tell these stories
that our community
and our nation
as a whole will better
understand the history
of our nation.
We may never be able to fully
repay our veterans for all
that they have done,
but this projects,
the Veterans History Project
is a great way to acknowledge
and to genuinely honor
these men and women
by archiving their
firsthand members, memories,
with the Library of Congress.
Today we have brought
with us the first
of what will be many interviews
that New Day USA will
complete, yes complete.
And this is a testimony of
service, and long service
and distinguished service of
Rear Admiral Thomas Lynch,
our chairman, and we
are pleased to turn
in this Living Touchstone over
to the Veterans History Project.
And I'll let Admiral
Lynch do that.
[ Applause ]
>> Admiral Thomas Lynch: Since I
have the floor here I will take
a moment to thank all
of you for being here
and particularly our panelists,
our Gold Star Mothers,
got my classmate here
Todd [inaudible] and six
and a half years as
a POW in Vietnam.
Bob [Inaudible] our CEO
of [inaudible] and CEO
who had the vision to
[inaudible] what we have
which was 5% of our
operating income.
We put that into our foundation,
and that foundation goes
out to help deserving
Gold Star families.
You saw beautiful Caroline
up here a moment ago,
the impact that can have.
We have how many, how many do
we have at your school now?
>> Lt. Gen. William
B. Caldwell: Thirteen.
>> Admiral Thomas Lynch:
Thirteen going to 1,300 we hope.
Of those who are sons
and daughters of deceased
or disabled members, or who
are fighting this global war
on terror on our behalf.
Those who, as we've said
before, service before self,
that's what it's all about
when you wear that uniform.
I just wish as Mort said earlier
in the program that more members
of Congress who aren't here
or their staff to understand
so they've got to know,
and that's one thing I think we
can do is, is, is be more vocal
up on The Hill, despite all
the division, divisiveness
that we have in our
country today.
I think they'd come together
for the person in uniform
who is making those sacrifices
and the family that has gone
through so much grief
and anguish.
So to all of you, I feel
very humbled and very proud
to be a part of New Day.
Very humbled in your presence,
and we're very thankful
that we can participate
in this program
with The Library of Congress.
We congratulate the Library of
Congress for making this happen.
And we just hope that more
and more of us can get out
and do more and more
in the future.
Thank you.
>> Mort Dean: Thank you Admiral.
>> Admiral Thomas
Lynch: Thank you Mort.
[ Applause ]
>> Al Banks: I just would like
to thank you for the collection,
and on behalf of the Library of
Congress present you and New Day
with a Certificate
of Appreciation.
And the collections
will be made available
through the Veterans History
Project to the American people.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Mort Dean: Thank you
all for being here and I,
I know I got a lot out of this,
and I'm sure all of you did too.
Thank you very much and
thank you to the Library
of Congress and to New Day USA.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.